Okay.
Looks like everything is in order.
Hello everyone.
I'm here with,
uh,
Dr. Jordan Peterson and um,
a lot of you probably know of him and
he's been making quite the bus.
Uh,
hi Jordan.
Thank you so much for,
for joining me on this chat.
I'm really excited to talk to get,
um,
to get to the topics at hand.
How are you doing today?
Good.
Yeah.
Well that's good.
Um,
I know you told me that there were some
very specific things that you'd like to
kind of talk to,
uh,
talk with me about today because we
don't have much time.
I just want to kind of jump right into
it.
So,
um,
you wanted to talk a bit about
postmodernism and their view on
categories.
Um,
did you want to just,
I'd be trying to,
obviously this discussion about pronouns
is attracting a tremendous amount of
attention and it's attracted a
tremendous amount of tension for complex
reasons that it's not an obvious wise
boy.
Everyone would focus on it for such a
long period of time.
It's been about 40 days now,
but 130 print articles.
And I would say maybe upwards of 3
million people have been watching the
goings on online.
Um,
and we haven't even counted the number
of youtube videos and that sort of thing
that would be generated as a consequence
of it.
And the two demonstrations at the
University of Toronto and the exchange
of letters,
it's,
it's been absurdly,
absurdly controversial and that means
that there's something going on that
people really haven't put their finger
on.
And I'd be thinking about it at multiple
levels of analysis.
And there's one very deep level of
analysis that I don't think anyone has
addressed.
And I would think about it as a,
as a cognitive level of analysis.
And it has to do with the nature of
categorization itself.
So I remember a long while back,
I read a paper on why human beings have
two hemispheres,
right hemisphere and the left
hemisphere,
roughly speaking,
the left hemisphere.
And this is very roughly speaking,
the left slash linguistic hemisphere
attempts to impose predictable structure
on the world.
Simplifying it.
It's not exactly an ideological
simplification.
It's more like a practical
simplification because the world is so
complex that unless you chunk it into
categories,
it overwhelms you.
And so you have to chunk it into
categories.
And those categories aren't exactly
descriptions of things or objects.
They're more like tools for operating in
the world.
And then the right hemisphere keeps
track of anomalies and exceptions and
tries to build those slowly into the
category system so that it doesn't blow
the category system.
And so there was an example of this that
that researcher named Goldberg offered.
He had trained a neural network to
recognize images of fish and the same
neural network to recognize images of
birds.
But when he showed it a penguin,
then it blew the category structure so
that all fish became birds and all birds
became fish.
Now the postmodernists like Derrida
claimed that category structures were
primarily tools of power and oppression,
which,
which to me is an absurd claim because
that's not their primary use,
even though that may be one of their
consequences and one of their own
occasionally uses.
And he became very,
very concerned about who the category
systems marginalized and what the
consequence of that was for them.
And that got tangled in,
in a,
in a sense,
into the Marxist identity politics
routine because the Marxist identity
politics,
people picked up the idea of the
excluded and marginalized and sort of
transform them into the equivalent of
Marx's oppressed working class and then
started to agitate for them.
And the Democrats in the United States,
for example,
transformed their focus from working
class,
uh,
concern say to identity politics
concerns.
And there's been some notion that that
was part of the resurgence of Marxism as
a,
as a new ideological doctrine.
Anyways,
it's a really fundamental problem.
The pro,
the pro categories exclude.
But then if you include the excluded in
the category,
you blow the category structure.
Now this is partly why the right wing
Christians,
for example,
were so opposed to the idea of
homosexual marriage.
So what,
what happened?
What's happening very rapidly is that
because of the binary category has been,
uh,
let's call,
let's say,
violated.
That's one way of thinking about it.
You get an explosion of chaotic
identities.
And so it's gone from say two to the
proposed,
I suppose three,
which,
which would have been what the
formulators of the legislation,
I think we're hoping for to say 31 in
New York and 70 online.
And then there's this additional
explosion which is,
which has being promoted by people who,
who aren't really concerned so much with
the categories of gender identity but
with other categories like human versus
non human identity.
And so those are the people that have
been come known as other kids or even
trans abled,
right?
Who are,
who are claiming but on the same logical
gout grounds.
That's the problem.
It's on the same logical grounds is
they're claiming a non categorical
identity that transcends the human.
And if it's,
if it's only subjective,
then there's no,
and you already agree with the first
step.
There's no way of logically agreeing
with the second step.
And so it's a really interesting example
of the,
of how say binary categories maintain
order.
And then if you violate them to include
those who are excluded,
what you produce is and up swelling of,
of,
of unmanageable chaos,
which seems to be the state where,
so one of the things I wanted to you is,
I think this is happening,
this is happening on two fronts.
It's happened with the,
with the requests of gay people to be
included in,
in,
in marriage,
and now now what's happened as a
consequence of the request of
transgendered people to be included in,
although flipping the gender category.
So this is especially true with the
non-gender non so-called nonbinary
gender types.
And so I just wondered what you think
about all that.
Wow.
There's so much.
Um,
so I've been thinking about this a lot.
Maybe not an insider in the same kind of
uses the same words,
but very much along the same lines.
Uh,
I,
I think it's interesting that you talk
about categories.
One could look at it also as not just
that,
the violation or the changing of it,
of it,
um,
the definition of a category,
but the creation of entirely new
category.
Um,
not just male,
female,
but now in tiny new category.
Um,
which not necessarily,
um,
threatens male and female,
but it threatens the dichotomy as you
said,
the binary.
Um,
and uh,
I find it interesting because I can't,
personally I don't,
I can't see how there is any third
agenda because
okay.
There is nothing more than male and
female.
I mean,
where,
where does this come from?
There's nothing more than male,
female and male.
That's exactly,
that's right.
Well that's exactly the problem of the
category is that once you're outside
that then your anywhere as far as I can
tell,
and if you can create an identity out of
math thing based out of nothing in
reality,
then you're basically claiming the
status of a Danny Guide and
doesn't make sense.
In fact,
the other kids are consciously claiming
the status of Demi gods because they,
they,
they proclaim that they are such
creatures as Alps or ferris or,
or orcs or whatever,
whatever their imagination conscious up.
But you know that that's the other thing
too,
is that in the,
in bill see 16,
there's actually an assault on the
concept of reality because identity is
technically unmoored from its
biological,
some straight.
And so that means it's unmoored from the
objective and as soon as it's on board
from the objective,
then it's subjective.
And in principle can be anything.
So I mean in,
here's the problem for,
so with the classically transgendered
people,
and I presume that you would fit into
that category,
the argument isn't so much about the
category of gender.
The argument is about which category
you're going to be in.
That what that seems to do is
immediately opened the door or has
opened the door to,
I would say a philosophical assault on
the concept of gender itself.
With that culminated,
for example,
in Dr Nicholas maps,
um,
claim on TV Ospi agenda when he was
debating me that there were no
biological differences between men and
women and that that's what the science
over the last four decades has claimed a
remarkable,
remarkable claims.
Basically,
it's not correct that there is such a
thing as biological sex.
And I'm a historian of medicine.
I can unpack that for you at great
length if you want.
But in the interest of time I won't.
So that's a very popular misconceptions.
So essentially when in my transgender
studies classes,
what we're doing is looking at actual
research and identifying ways that
current social issues related to trans
people or things that are associated
with trans,
such as free speech arguments and
claims.
Uh,
how that connects to the way that people
are thinking.
And the way that research has been
framed,
the history is there were some of the
other pronouns
and then the dissolution of identity
into this unbelievable chaos that that
even appears to transcend that,
that the dimensions of,
of species.
I got an article today from,
from a viewer in England who sent me the
transcripts,
I believe it was of the German
philosophers talk,
who claimed that our recognition of the
biological sex of animals is nothing but
an artificial imposition of our
arbitrary ideological construct,
which is exactly what you'd,
you'd claim if you,
if you,
if you decided that the underlying
biology was irrelevant.
This is why I think the evolutionary
biologists are next in the sights of the
social justice warriors.
Absolutely.
I think there is a degree to which even
a traditional,
uh,
transgender be pulled do still maybe not
assault,
but certainly threatened,
uh,
the,
the category of male and female.
Suddenly,
I,
I tried to argue for why I,
why we need to consider a definition of
woman that maybe include someone like
me.
I don't demand it.
I just argue for it.
Um,
but then there's the other thing that I,
the other matter that you seem to talk
about more,
which is the inclusion of a new
categories such as non binary and what
that means to the mat,
the,
the meaning of gender.
But I think including a trans woman into
the category of woman,
uh,
maybe not equally,
but similarly,
uh,
threatened,
um,
the definition of gender.
Um,
in a similar way,
maybe not assault.
Um,
it definitely destabilizes it.
And,
and the question is what exactly should
be done about that?
Because you know there's been a
claimable say western philosopher since
I really think since the beginning of
the philosophical tradition that the
basis of civilization itself,
the structural basis is,
is roughly speaking the nuclear family.
And another thing I think that's come
under assault,
and this is certainly something that was
picked up by the cross to Christian
fundamentalists early,
was that the dissolution of these
categories,
structures also to destabilize the
nuclear family.
And the problem with that is we don't
exactly know what the consequences of
that will be.
We do know the scientific literature is
quite clear on this as far as I'm
concerned,
children who are raised in intact
families with two biological parents do
far better on every,
or pretty much everything that's
measured.
And so now of course the problem with
the family,
and you can see this reflected in say
Kathleen wins new legislation on,
I think it's called the old families are
equal.
That's the bill,
is that if any arrangement whatsoever
between people can be family,
then there's no such thing as family
anymore.
And if there's no such thing as family,
well then we don't know what will
happen.
And the problem too is that it seems to
me that it's in the interest of people
who are non,
who do not fit easily into categories to
not destabilize the main culture too
badly.
And there's a reason for that is the
main culture right now is actually
pretty tolerant.
If you'd be stabilized at culture
enough,
it,
it will become rapidly intolerant.
And then the first thing that happens is
those who are identifiably different are
the first targets of an intolerant
culture.
So it seems to me that it's incumbent on
the lbgt,
et Cetera community.
If they want to request inclusion,
then they also have to figure out how
that can be done in a way that doesn't
destabilize the entire category
structure because it it risks doing
that.
So now you had some arguments about why
the category of woman should be expanded
to include people like you.
Now obviously you're doing everything in
your power to present yourself to the
world in a manner that makes you easily
categorizable.
Absolutely.
And I guess I don't necessarily even
think of it that way.
You know,
I don't think,
uh,
I want to be seen as woman.
So I'm going to do all these things to
be viewed as woman.
Um,
I do all these things because I am a
woman.
Um,
I do all these things just because it
comes naturally to me.
And the end product happens to be,
uh,
a subject that in people's minds is
easily register a ball.
Well that's also,
I would say that's an act of politeness
on your part,
you know,
so,
so one of the things people concluded
when I first made my videos is that I
wouldn't use he or she to to,
uh,
refer to,
I'll say someone like yourself who wants
to be referred to as she.
And my attitude about that was never
that.
But having thought through it further,
I also realized that my natural
behavioral proclivity,
and I think that most people is to refer
to someone by the protein chro pronoun
that addresses their appearance because
it's,
it's a,
it's a pronoun use is actually rather
casual,
right?
You do it unthinkingly in automatically.
And you address a person in keeping with
the manner in which they manifest
themselves.
And,
and you're doing that,
you're saying that that's also a,
or maybe even primarily a manifestation
of an inner drive,
but obviously the,
the manner in which that inner drive is
manifest itself is also socially,
it's part of a social negotiation.
Of course.
That's probably my argument for choosing
a definition of women that includes me,
uh,
because for the sake of communication it
just seems,
makes sense.
Language is what we use to communicate
with one another.
We don't want to corrupt it.
The better we communicate the real world
to on and not that the Beta we use
language and I think there would
actually be more confusion if people
refer to me as he on sa and stuff.
So part of your cases that is actually
no way of addressing you.
That doesn't produce some confusion.
And so using she is the simplest,
which is less confused.
Okay.
That's an interesting argument.
So what would you say if I said you
could make a case that your mere
existence is a threat to categorical
order?
And so I could say that your duty as a
consequence,
despite the potential violation of your
own sense of self,
would be to what?
To deny your own inner impulses and
conform because not doing so I
understand that that comes at a personal
cost.
And I'm not trying to minimize that
And I'm also not saying that you should
do this,
but I think you can make a case that
it's like,
it's like the social obligation of
someone who doesn't fit into a
fundamental category too tricky one man
to fit in regardless because it's so
threatening not to.
No,
I mean you could make the same case
about artists.
That's the problem,
right?
You could make the same case about
anyone but doesn't fit in and often
people who don't fit in our necessary.
So it's a very tricky thing to think
through.
Well,
I'd like to come back to the argument
for a usefulness of language,
uh,
like how useful is the definition of
women,
you know,
for the most part,
using a definition of lemon,
someone who was on with xx chromosomes
and,
and you now can give birth.
And you know,
all of those things that's very useful
because it describes the vast majority
of cases that you will find in real
world.
And it facilitates certain kinds of
interactions.
I mean,
so I don't see that it's necessarily
conflicting.
Two can set it in a given situation.
We saw him and he was not born
biologically female to consider the use
of a different definition of women if
it's Camina communicatively useful.
And that way we don't have to,
we don't have to threaten categories
because we were still committed to.
Okay.
Um,
okay,
so let,
so let me ask you some questions about
that.
So let's assume that your point is well
taken then I might say,
if you're born a man and you wish to be
treated as a woman,
what are the minimal obligations that
you have to undertake in order to be
granted that,
let's say privilege?
You know,
because the way this is framed,
right,
the way it's been framed and discussions
with me so far is that it's a matter of
respect to you,
someone's pronouns.
And I think that's nonsense because when
I see people on the street and I
referred to them as he or she,
it has nothing to do with respect.
It's just,
it's just the most casual of
communication in camps.
And so,
so I don't buy the respect thing,
but let's say you're making a case that
the most straight forward thing is to
include you or,
or people that are in the same position
as you.
So what do you think your obligations
are?
Your responsibilities are to the social
compact,
but say in order to be given that I got
to saint privilege,
it's something like that because it's
okay.
Privilege is fine with me.
I think that,
um,
considering that my answer to that
question would be
to be regarded as the gender that you
identify eyes common sensically within
your culture.
Maybe.
Maybe that's your obligation.
Yeah,
I'm okay.
Well that seems to be at least
reasonable because at least then you
don't make it any more awkward for
people to interact with you than it has
to be.
I was talking to an artist the other day
named Jonathan Patio and we were talking
about the issue of,
of non categorical identity and he,
he was talking to me about um,
mythological stories of the welcoming of
strangers.
There's a very strong tradition of
hospitality in most cultures and if a
stranger shows up here to welcome them
into your house,
but they're supposed to behave when
they're in your house so they're not
supposed to steal all your vaccine.
Right.
And rape your women and so forth.
Right,
exactly.
So there's an obligation on both sides.
Right?
Like what,
like what Gavin McInnes said about
trans,
who transitioned from male to female.
You said that you're not,
if you're going to go to Japan and
you're going to go live in Japan,
do you need to like speak their language
to communicate with them,
adopt our costumes,
take your shoes off when you enter the
enter the house were referred by their
last name,
all these things.
That's just what you do.
That's what a stranger does if they
don't want to be considered a stranger
anymore.
Right,
exactly.
Exactly that.
Yeah.
Something.
Well,
so it seems to me that there needs to be
a discussion about responsibilities.
If,
if the excluded other wants to be
included.
The way to be included isn't to blow
apart the category structure.
It's to make faculty behaves nicely when
you're welcomed into the house.
It's something like that.
Okay,
so I've got a more,
a more vicious question to ask you.
I would say this is a rough one man.
Like caught like the,
the,
the majority of his live stream of,
because then a transphobic,
transphobic by probably every trend,
the majority of trans people.
I love it.
I think this is
such good comments.
Okay,
so here's,
now here's another problem.
One of the things that I've been
thinking through the last couple of
weeks is the idea of discrimination
because discrimination and judgment and
categorization aren't that easy to tell
apart and you have to be discriminating
or you'll do anything all the time.
Do you have to mcallen?
But you have to exclude.
Now,
one of the things that's very
characteristic about seeing the sexual
behavior among human beings is it's very
exclusionary.
So,
for example,
among chimpanzees,
the females are promiscuous meters.
Now the dominant males have more
offspring,
but that's because they chase the
subordinate males away from the females
when they're in estrous,
when they're in heat,
the females that are in heat,
they'll meet with any male.
The dominant males chase away the
subordinate males,
so they get more offspring.
But it has nothing to do with female,
let's say preference.
Human beings are very strange in this
regard,
and this is maybe why we're so different
from chimpanzees,
even though we share a common ancestor.
And one of the big differences is that
human females are very,
very choosy sexually.
And so this is why,
for example,
you have twice as many female ancestors
as mail APP ancestors.
And it's a hard thing to think about
conceptually,
but basically it means that on average,
every,
you'd get that outcome.
If on average,
every female produced two offspring and
every male only produced one.
Now that would mean some males produce
far more than one and some produced
zero.
So there's differential sexual success
in males and females in human beings.
It's because of female sexual
selectivities.
So this is what females choose before
they choose men who are across or above
them.
In dominance hierarchies,
they tend to choose for health.
They tend to choose for appearance.
They tend to choose for productivity
that's manifested often in status and so
forth.
And so what that means is that a
minority of males are found very
sexually attractive and the majority of
males not.
So my point is is that one of the most
fundamental rights that say feminists
want to retain is the right to absolute
sexual choice in their partners.
But they don't understand that that's
based on exactly the forms of
discrimination that they're always
arguing against.
So because you generally,
people sleep with someone up their own
race,
they sleep with someone of their own
religion roughly the same age.
They generally go after healthy people.
They generally go after attractive
people.
And so every single dimension of
discrimination that you can possibly
imagine governs sexual choice.
If you completely eradicate the
justification for discrimination,
which I would also say is the same
justification for freedom of
association,
you also blow out the element of sexual
choice.
No.
The question I wanted to ask you is,
considering you as a potential sexual
partner is going to be distressing to
the majority of people.
Is that acceptable?
Yes.
Why?
Because,
um,
I'm an anomaly.
It's just not something people
comfortable with.
Uh,
the fact that I was born a different way
than I am now,
even if they are attracted to me,
it makes my dating life a bit harder.
But I mean I'm a huge proponent of
discrimination.
I think that's 100% within people's
rights.
Uh,
I would never call us on transphobic
because they don't want to seek with me
because I was born one way and that's
their preference as their prerogative.
It's 100% people's right to
discriminate.
So do you think that there's any ways,
obviously you saw to this through a lot,
like the part of the problem here is
that distinguishing that from forbidden
forms of discrimination is very,
very difficult conceptually.
Like it's not obvious why it's okay to
discriminate against someone sexually.
This happened in brave new world in
Huxley's novel where any form of sexual
discrimination was regarded as socially
inappropriate,
such that if someone asks you to have
sex with them,
it was your moral obligation,
not only to do it,
but to be happy about the basic
hypothesis was,
or the basic slogan was everyone belongs
to everyone else.
That's the final limit of the absence of
discrimination.
So,
but why do you think that discrimination
of that sword is okay?
I believe in equality and lack of
discrimination,
equal treatment under the law.
That is kind of where it ends for me.
Very much free market.
And my thinking,
um,
well the free market example's an
interesting one because maybe the
reasons and that it's okay for other
people to discriminate is because we
want to retain the right for ourselves
to discriminate because mate,
maybe it's something like you're willing
to have people reject you as a potential
sexual partner as long as you're also
allowed the privilege to reject other
people as opposed to it.
I'll take that type things on both,
uh,
the,
the whole transgender people in
Washington's thing.
I believed when that was going on.
It's kind of died down now.
But I believe when that was going on
that's the state shouldn't be saying,
uh,
trans people aren't allowed in,
in,
in the washroom of their choosing or
shouldn't I,
I was like,
that's up to the business owners to make
that decision.
Is this a,
a business down the road of restaurant
that wouldn't let me,
you know,
use the washroom,
the female washroom,
so be it.
I'll just go to a different restaurant
and that's why I'm so,
I'm very free market thinking and I,
I,
I think discrimination is something that
needs to,
the right to discriminate is something
that needs to be protected at all costs.
It certainly seems to have to be
protected to some degree.
I think the sexual choice conundrum,
I mean there were horrors on both sides
of it,
right?
The first horror is,
well,
if you obliterate sexual discrimination,
then you have to allow yourself to,
to be the sexual target of whoever when
ever that seems like pretty bad
solution.
And it's certainly not one that I think
particularly women would rapidly accept.
And that's such an assault individuals
agency,
right?
Right.
It's the ultimate assault on an
individual's agency,
but the problem is is to maintain that
right to choice is to also maintain the
right to discriminate and then putting
the boundaries on what you're allowed to
discriminate against is very,
very tricky.
Like I think we've gone far too far in
in the,
in the antidiscrimination direction.
It's very difficult for people on
campuses now to aggregate themselves in
gender uniform groups.
And I'm not sure that's a good idea.
I like,
it seems to me that men should be
allowed to hang around with men if they
want to and that women should be allowed
to hang around with women when they want
to and that actually that right might be
necessary for the proper development of
masculinity and femininity.
What one final thing,
this is another horrible thing that no
one ever talks about.
The data suggests that men who are
homosexual have a very large number of
sexual partners,
and that makes sense to me because men
tend not to say no to sexual
opportunities.
And so my man with man,
it's like no one says no.
So there's lots of sexual activity.
Well,
so one of the things I'm curious about
is if marriage is expanded on any other
grounds merely than the legal grounds,
which I think aren't sufficient to even
maintain marriage as an,
as an institution,
if marriage is expanded to include same
sex couples,
say what are the obligations of the same
sex couples once they're actually
married?
So does that mean that that,
and I know the literature on this,
that the suggestion is that most male
homosexuals who get married don't give
up.
They're promiscuous ways.
Well,
it seems to me that if you don't give up
your permissionless ways,
then you're actually not playing the
game of marriage.
And that's why it's one of the
discussions about responsibility that I
don't think has been had in public land.
If you want to be part of the game,
then in principle you also have to
follow the rules.
So that doesn't mean everyone who's
heterosexual who's managed.
You absolutely obliterate the very
fundamental building blocks of a society
and a culture.
That's what happens when,
uh,
when you,
when you violent,
very important categories like marriage,
right?
That's right.
You know,
we don't know what the fundamentals,
we don't really understand the
fundamentals.
I mean people,
people have need philosophical claims.
I would say gender identity is a
fundamental.
Children learn that very early and
marriage is a fundamental and the
nuclear family is a fundamental and you
know,
we,
we have no idea how many of those
fundamentals can be challenged before
the whole bloody thing shakes and falls
down and it,
unless you wanted to shake and fall
down.
All right,
so good.
Well that was good.
So maybe we're going to do this again
everyone,
everyone please check the link below to
register for the right to offend
conference.
Uh,
on November 19th.
Um,
it's going to be Greg,
we'll be talking about some of the
topics surrounding a political
correctness,
free speech and so on.
And uh,
I wanted to have this live stream
because a Dr. Peterson wasn't able to,
wouldn't be able to make it in person
for that conference.
So I just wanted to use this time to
promote it.
Thank you so much,
Dr. Peterson.
All right.
Okay.
Bye.
Bye Bye.